>> Will Sentance: Braydon, tiếp tục đi Braydon.
>> Diễn giả 2: Vì vậy, nếu chúng tôi đang cố gắng sử dụng dữ liệu lưu trữ dữ liệu từ mạng
yêu cầu, thực hiện như thế nào nếu bạn có một dòng mã trong JavaScript, trong toàn cầu.
Làm thế nào nó biết khi nào nó có thể truy cập nó?
>> Will Sentance: Hậu trường trong thực tế,
giá trị cao này không bao giờ được điền vào trên thực tế.
Cho đến khi tất cả các mã toàn cầu chạy xong, vì vậy chúng tôi thậm chí không thể truy cập vào nó tại thời điểm đó
cho đến khi chúng tôi có, chúng tôi chỉ có quyền truy cập vào nó từ phía trước.
Và theo cách đó, ý tôi là khác với mô hình gọi lại, phải không?
Bạn chỉ có quyền truy cập từ chức năng mà chúng tôi thêm vào,
chúng tôi cũng đã kích hoạt bởi vì chúng tôi không muốn có ngôn ngữ.
Nơi chúng ta có thể đi và
thử và có quyền truy cập vào nội dung và chúng tôi không biết liệu nó có ở đó hay không.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi không thực sự tự động điền điều đó vào hậu trường,
cho đến khi tất cả các mã toàn cầu chạy xong.
Được rồi, trong thực tế, điều đó có một hậu quả nhỏ.
Nhưng nó hơi khác so với cách tôi đã cho bạn thấy ở đây, nơi chúng tôi
ngụ ý rằng nó được điền vào đây ngay lúc đó.
Nhưng thực tế là vào phút cuối cùng,
trước khi chúng tôi bắt đầu đi qua hàng đợi.
Điều đó không có hậu quả về mặt.
Chúng tôi không chạy các chức năng này cho đến khi nó được điền vào,
cho đến khi chúng tôi hoàn thành tất cả mã toàn cầu để không có hậu quả.
Dấu?
>> Người nói 2: Tôi đang cố gắng nghĩ cách diễn đạt điều này cho đúng.
>> Will Sentance: Bạn có muốn dành một giây?
>> Người nói 2: Tôi có thể thử.
Nếu đó là lời chào in khi trình duyệt có nó, thì đó là tham chiếu đến lời chào in toàn cầu.
Không in hello chính nó.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, chúng tôi không đưa vào trình duyệt web một bản sao của
chức năng.
Chúng tôi chỉ đưa ra một tham chiếu trở lại trong bộ nhớ, chức năng này, vâng.
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Có thể in lời chào, hãy xem xét thời điểm bạn nhấn
văn bản chi phí một cái gì đó tham số khác từ bộ nhớ chung?
Hoặc là nó phải được có thể.
>> Will Sentance: Sẽ rất khó để làm như vậy, bởi vì.
>> Người nói 2: Vâng. >> Di chúc: Chờ đã,
ai đang in những tờ giấy bạc?
Xin chào, chúng tôi đang làm điều đó, vâng.
Chúng ta đang đặt bản in trên bản in?
Xin chào? >> Người nói 2: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Không có JavaScript đang làm điều đó.
Nếu chúng ta không đặt thương hiệu vào làm cách nào để chèn bất kỳ đối số nào?
Chúng ta phải dựa vào sự hiểu biết.
Và đây là một điểm thực sự tốt, đáng làm nhất ở đây.
Nó có nghĩa là chúng ta phải biết chẳng hạn như
bạn có thể trả lời một dấu cách khác, hãy chờ.
Tôi có thể có hai đối số được chuyển cho tôi, đó là tất cả về hiển thị hàm
nhận đầu vào đầu tiên của nó.
Dữ liệu quay trở lại như thể tôi chỉ có thể mong đợi hai đối số.
Bây giờ, tôi phải đi và
xem chính xác tính năng của trình duyệt web mà chức năng này hoạt động như thế nào
sẽ được tự động kích hoạt khi trình duyệt web tính năng kết thúc hoạt động.
Nó mong đợi như thế nào trình duyệt web và
lời hứa của bệnh mong đợi chức năng này được đặt ra.
Tôi phải đi đâu để tìm các quy tắc về điều đó?
Tôi đang ở đâu để tìm ra cách trình duyệt mong đợi chức năng
sẽ được tự động chạy.
Khi công việc của nó được hoàn thành sẽ hoạt động và nó sẽ cần những đầu vào nào?
Làm thế nào để tôi tìm ra điều đó, mọi người?
Cho dù đó là một trang web.
>> Diễn giả 2: MDN. >> Will Sentance: Shutting
MDN, chính xác.
MDN đã có một danh sách tất cả các tính năng này.
Họ không gọi những chức năng mặt tiền này.
Họ gọi chúng là API là viết tắt của giao diện là bất kỳ chức năng nào hoặc
thường là dữ liệu không có trong thế giới của tôi, nhưng trong thế giới của người khác và tôi giao tiếp với nó.
Đây là những nhãn của tôi mà tôi có thể tương tác với
thế giới bên ngoài này.
Điều đó được nói hơi liên quan đến những gì bạn đang nói, Mark,
giả sử tôi đặt lệnh gọi thời gian chờ bên trong thực thi và chức năng khác.
Và nó muốn sử dụng một số dữ liệu từ ngữ cảnh thực thi đó.
Chà, vào lúc bản in hello chạy, nó chạy trên toàn cầu,
ngữ cảnh thực thi mà trong đó thời gian chờ đã đặt với thiết lập đã hết,
và tất cả dữ liệu của nó đã biến mất, trừ khi- >> Loa 2: Ba lô.
>> Will Sentance: Ba lô, chính xác, in hello có một liên kết đến tất cả xung quanh của nó
bộ nhớ có thể được sử dụng trong đó, khá tuyệt vời, điều đó thật tuyệt vời.
Được rồi, chúng tôi đã có một cái khác, vâng, Jason, làm ơn?
>> Người nói 2: [COUGH] Xin lỗi, vì vậy ví dụ ít nhất cũng cho chúng ta ấn tượng
rằng hàng đợi vi tác vụ ở đầu tiên,
cuối cùng, nơi nó được sử dụng ưu tiên- >> Will Sentance: Câu hỏi hay.
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Nơi bạn nhận được tùy thuộc vào loại cuộc gọi bạn sẽ nhận được
một hàng đợi.
Tôi nghi ngờ là nhiệm vụ vi mô thực sự có vòng lặp phát minh riêng của nó
>> Di chúc: Bởi vì không,
sự kiện cần xử lý.
Hãy nói một chút về cách các từ trong hàng đợi nhiệm vụ vi mô liên quan đến những gì Jason
hỏi họ.
Nếu không thực sự thú vị thì sao?
Vì vậy, hóa ra với các đối tượng hứa, tôi chỉ có thể tạo một đối tượng trực tiếp.
Tôi không cần phải tạo nó tự động bằng cách tìm nạp,
Tôi thực sự chỉ có thể nói tạo một.
Nếu sau đó tôi nói giải quyết điều đó, nghĩa là nói trong dòng mã đó trong thời điểm đó.
Để nó tự động hoàn thành và
có chức năng của nó mà tôi có thể kiểm soát chức năng đó.
Chúng tôi có thể làm điều đó với tìm nạp.
Bởi vì tìm nạp đang xử lý mối quan hệ ở đây, nhưng
nếu tôi tạo đối tượng hứa hẹn của riêng mình, thì tôi có thể có chức năng gắn liền với nó.
Tôi có thể trực tiếp đưa nó vào hàng đợi microtask bằng cách
thuộc tính giá trị của đối tượng lời hứa đó được cập nhật và hoàn thành.
Và tự động kích hoạt chức năng để chạy trong hàng đợi microtask.
Đây là một kịch bản thực sự thú vị.
Nếu khi tôi chạy chức năng trong microtask của tôi
hàng đợi đã được hiển thị, Nếu bên trong đó.
Tôi tạo một đối tượng hứa hẹn hoàn toàn mới với chức năng liên quan của nó
trong khi tôi đang ở bên trong màn hình.
Đối tượng lời hứa đó đã hoàn thành vì tôi đã trực tiếp nói với nó,
chức năng liên quan sẽ bị kẹt vào phần phụ trợ của hàng đợi microtask trong khi tôi
vẫn hiển thị bên trong.
>> Will Sentance: Đây thực sự là
tình huống thú vị có thể xảy ra sau đó.
Tôi có thể điền vào phía sau hàng đợi nhiệm vụ vi mô với nhiều hơn
các chức năng trong khi tôi vẫn ở bên trong màn hình.
Và vòng lặp sự kiện rất thú vị và
cách nó tương tác với hàng đợi nhiệm vụ vi mô là một phần thưởng rất, rất lớn.
Nếu bạn truy cập nếu bạn muốn biết các phần cứng của nút, chúng ta sẽ đi vào một số chi tiết hơn.
Họ lo lắng quá nhiều về điều này.
Nhưng tôi đang cảm thấy nếu tôi muốn tôi đang ở bên trong màn hình và
điền vào các chức năng mới ở đây.
Và chính họ đang xây dựng một chức năng mới.
Và sau đó đó là những chức năng khá mới gần như đệ quy.
Tôi sẽ không bao giờ rời khỏi hàng đợi microdose vì vòng lặp sự kiện
sẽ luôn nhận và thực thi trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Nó sẽ luôn quay trở lại và
kiểm tra microtask trước khi nó chuyển sang hàng đợi gọi lại.
Điều đó phân biệt với hàng đợi gọi lại mà một khi nó vào sẽ làm tất cả
những thứ ở đó và sau đó lại di chuyển vòng quanh.
Hàng đợi microtask khi nó vào,
nếu bạn đang nạp lại ở phía sau, bạn sẽ không rời khỏi nó.
Bạn nhận được cái gọi là bỏ đói hàng đợi gọi lại và trong Node.
Điều này đặc biệt quan trọng vì bạn muốn, bạn biết đấy, ứng dụng sản xuất.
Và đây là lý do tại sao cần thận trọng khi sử dụng
quy trình tiếp theo phương pháp đánh dấu.
Cái nào dính những thứ trong hàng đợi này và
đệ quy có thể bỏ đói bạn khi xử lý các yêu cầu từ người dùng của bạn.
Tôi chủ đề Valence, nhưng hãy xem Node Harper's, bạn quan tâm đến điều đó, nhưng
đó là một bản chất thú vị mà chúng đang hoạt động hơi khác một chút.
Đúng như Jason đang gợi ý, còn một Brayden nữa, có phải là
đó là Peter hay Kayla?
Dan, đó là Dan, vâng, tiếp tục đi Dan.
>> Người nói 2: Vâng khi bạn có thể đã đề cập đến điều này, nhưng.
Những mục nào đi vào hàng đợi microtask và những mục nào đi vào.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, điểm tuyệt vời.
Hãy thực sự rõ ràng.
Bất kỳ hàm nào được gắn vào một đối tượng hứa hẹn bởi một trong hai ngạnh này cho
các chức năng được lưu trữ.
Để thêm một đối tượng hứa, chúng tôi đính kèm một hàm vào nó bằng cách sử dụng chúng.
Các chức năng đó đều đi vào nhiệm vụ vi mô bạn nhé.
Bất kỳ hàm nào được chuyển trực tiếp đến một hàm mặt tiền để kích hoạt web
tính năng trình duyệt, bạn xem tham chiếu liên kết đến chức năng ở đây.
Các chức năng đó khi chúng hoàn thành hoặc
xin lỗi khi nhiệm vụ nền bộ hẹn giờ hoàn thành gọi lại chức năng này.
Vì vậy, chúng ta phải đi vào MDN và
xem, mặt tiền cụ thể của chúng ta có chức năng kích hoạt nội dung trong nền không?
Nó có trong một chức năng?
Người đó sẽ đi vào hàng đợi gọi lại?
Hay nó quay trở lại thành một đối tượng hứa hẹn và
chúng ném xuống nền nhưng không ném một hàm xuống đây.
Hàm kết hợp trên đối tượng hứa hẹn, hàng đợi microtask đó.
Được rồi, ngọt ngào.